Mary is with us in Washington hey Mary
what's up hi thank you for taking my
call um I would like to talk to dr. John
about so I'd like to save my marriage
but honestly I am so tired mostly and
otherwise and I want to find out how to
get past the resentment and to a place
of forgiveness so we've been on our debt
journey for a long time we've been on
Dave's plan for over seven years and
we're still on baby step two
I found Dave on the radio and got our
home finances in order really quickly
then I found out that my husband to his
business had over $700,000 in debt
because apparently thought he was in
Congress but it's been a long hard road
okay so we're down to about 60,000 left
to pay off of his business debt and of
course now we have this gravida not
helpful
I am tired right now I try to
emotionally support him because business
is pretty tough and I so nobody
emotionally supports me I was just
writing that question down who motional
II supports you but you know what I
can't
your kids are supported correct
like um adults but their kids and
truthfully we are kind of Dave ish
because I have some money saved at home
away from the business debt but our
youngest is in college and I'm committed
to cash flow in that college plus she
has a good scholarship and just working
and I I can't fix his business debt but
I can keep my kid from being trapped in
debt okay right so tell me about your
tell me about your marriage did he did
he admit a decade ago to financial
infidelity did he forget the admit to
hiding the stuff and is he hiding it I
mean he wasn't being malicious I mean he
was just just was what it was yeah
ignorant I mean I was not I'm working a
different job I work separate from his
business and so I was doing that and
raising the kids and it's good but
you're marrying him to take care of that
38 years married I mean I just trusted
him to do that stuff and I just think he
just I don't think it was malicious he
just didn't know it sounds to me like
you and your husband are on the same
page and I don't want it I don't want to
trivialize almost a million dollars of
debt I don't want to trivialize 40 years
of marriage but it sounds like you're
running an alternative life and then
you've got one with him and then you've
got one you're paying off debt you've
paid off your must you paid off almost a
million dollars in seven years yeah
problem you're at Mile 22 of the
marathon what's the problem no no I'm
just out of gas
I guess what why I mean you're
emotionally out of gas and you're almost
to the finish line unless he unless he
is if he's been in Reverse while you've
been pedaling ahead the whole time
that's different but why I mean why is
it I understand you're exhausted from
working on this so long but aren't you
both exhausted and hasn't he been arm in
arm with you I don't understand why I
mean you should be both stumbling
towards the finish line with the equal
level of fatigue because you paid off an
amazing amount of that I guess that's
true who are you and who are you and
what is your marriage when this is paid
off I don't know anymore
that's the question sometimes you tell
people we need to dream together and I
don't even know how to do that now okay
I'm gonna hold you through the three
we're gonna hold you through the break
and then we'll come back to you I think
because I think your situation speaks to
a lot of people's situation so let's
let's keep talking about it we're
talking with Mary in Washington they
started their journey
seven years ago they paid off 700,000
and business debt down to sixty thousand
plus all their home debts so hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt approaching a million dollars in
debt during this time Mary's out of
steam and is worried about our marriage
after this time and got enough got some
money in the bank to make sure the kid
last kid gets through school and he
wants to be supportive of her husband
but she's out of gas is that a very
quick summary what you told us Mary yes
how much money is in the bank for the
kids college about fifteen thousand okay
all right so it doesn't solve the
problem there's sixty thousand over at
the business right right
okay well the kovat thing is gonna
complicate that sure so we might called
your first statement was you want to
save this marriage and then as you kind
of worked your way through
I heard the hope drain from your voice
why are you hopeless right now I know
you're exhausted and you you guys paid
off six hundred forty thousand dollars
which is just past the resenting him
things stay home with the kids that was
my dream that's never gonna happen my
youngest kids 20 okay not even possible
and there's nothing that can get that
back I want to get past the resentment
so I can forgive him and just get past
the debt and move on okay so you're not
gonna like my statement on this but I
want you to hear me your choice to hold
on to the resentment is just that and at
some point you've got to make a decision
if I can put this in a duffel bag and
set it down
is it painful yes that it did it take
away the picture of the of the mom you
want it to be yes but it is it just
simply is and so a decision and in I
know it sounds like I'm trivializing
this I don't hear it that way but it's a
decision to hang on to this stuff for a
decade to lose the fact that you guys
have paid off six hundred forty thousand
dollars together and we're gonna I'm
gonna keep this going forward and then
suddenly we're gonna look up codes gonna
be over we're gonna pay the
60 grand off I'm gonna still be carrying
this around what about it can you not
let go no it's the only dream I had so I
need a replacement I guess I don't know
it you're hanging on and I use this word
intentionally you're hanging on to a
fantasy of what could have been and it's
just not and so now what's happening is
it's poisoning your current relationship
with your husband it's poisoning
relationship with your kids you're
creating a side world with your kids
where hey I'm gonna make sure you I'm
gonna do this for you and all the sudden
it's just the wedge between you and your
husband's getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and it's not about finances
anymore and it's not about it's about
this this poison that that lives in you
now and I'm what I let me ask you this
how has his once you discovered the dead
and once you guys agreed to work on it
together has he put his hand to the plow
for six years with you and cleaned this
debt up yes yes almost all that he does
at this point I mean so he's okay he's
done the job that you asked him to do
upon discovering it but and you've done
the job that you needed to do upon the
scarf oh yeah I've been working two jobs
to help him yeah fix his business yeah
and what I would suggest is y'all start
saying you've been working two jobs so
that we could fix our life because when
you keep it this is mine and this is his
and you divide the world up and to me
versus him you were never gonna come
together and save that marriage you want
to have your never gonna fully integrate
your kids into this partnership with
your husband she's never gonna work
because it's always gonna be you versus
him and if he hadn't have done this
thing this many years ago then we
wouldn't be an I wouldn't have had this
experience the experience is over it's
here it also sounds like you're
struggling with your kids going off to
college is that hard are you
empty-nester now actually I like a man
penis
good for you that's good that's very
good surprisingly yeah but good yes so
can make the same decision on resentment
and
oh it just doesn't serve you anywhere I
mean it what anger does is it shows us
that we care about seven years old
mm-hmm now seven years ago I would be
with you seven years ago if you wanted
to have a hissy fit duck fit in the
middle of the floor and flop around upon
discovering this and you know have a
real good six months of being pissed off
I go along with you six years later the
guy's been doing everything he's
supposed to do and you've been doing
everything you're supposed to do there's
no fill in an hour it's like were we're
both working really hard to achieve his
dream but mine never mattered and if you
continue to feel that way if you
continue to hear it that way your first
statement I want to not do that but I'm
trying to figure out so what you need to
do is you need to sit down on your
husband and you'll need to paint a new
picture you've got to decide this this
picture of what we were gonna live it's
gone so we can decide together and you
can lead this conversation and if he's a
guy that's willing to put his nose to
the plow like he has then he sounds like
he's a guy is gonna come to the table
with you and say I want to proactively
affirmatively paint a new picture of
what this is going to look like so we
have something to live for word we're
not continually running back from the
thing that happened a long time ago so
here's what's occurring to me I'm I'm
Way out of my league here listening to
John but um if you're gonna be mad and
resentful or you are mad and resentful
in the marriage or out of the marriage
you're still mad and resentful and you
still don't get those cogs back they're
gone the and the kid the kids are still
grown right so you're mad and resentful
in the marriage or your matters if
either marriage unless you may lay the
mat and resentful down and in either
case the kids still grow up it's over
that part of it's over yeah so now the
new vision is grandbabies right right
there we go
if you trained them right anyway you
will if it may take I don't actually
think you need professional help on this
one
I think you actually need to sit down
and write him a letter and write down
here the regrets I have but here is what
I'm willing to do to move forward and
here's the thing like you've mentioned
it
exhausted here at Mile 22 of this
marathon you're so close you're so close
everybody wants to quit at Mile 20 to
just keep going you're almost there and
make the decision to set the regret down
and paint a new picture you got to have
something to go towards you can't be
running from something so must marry the
closest thing I can relate this to is
when I went broke when we went broke
years ago the hardest part of that whole
thing for me was to get over being
pissed off at myself for having been so
stupid to build a house of cards I I
took the lash to my own back for quite a
while Sharon didn't say a thing for
about three years because we were just
trying to survive and then at that three
year mark at 10 years of marriage or
seven years of marriage went broke we
had this implosion because those
feelings that were stuffed down
resurrected and she suddenly was really
really pissed off three years later kind
of like you and so we had to way to sit
down and work on that with a marriage
counselor and and I had to learn to
forgive myself and in the process she
had learned to forgive me and you know
what was lost of what we lost the first
decade of our marriage to all the
stupidity that I had been engaged in and
in bad financial decisions bad business
decisions and it took away that and it
took away her this fantasy she had that
she had married Sir Galahad then she
discovered it was goobers you know I
mean and so that you know we really did
go through I guess a similar thing but I
you know it is an act of the will but
it's a process to go through laying that
down and saying okay I'm mad about that
but it is in the past
I'm resentful about that but it is in
the past and I did some really stupid
stuff in my case I'm in the past I can't
undo it I can't go back and fix it it's
there but we can get together and go
forward yeah but I can I can on the only
that shot I got is the windshield the
reason the rear view mirror is smaller
is that's called Grace I don't have to
live in
I can extend grace to myself and guests
in grace to others forgiveness to myself
forgiveness to others and I had to
because I was really torqued I was
really mad
at myself and then later on it took a
while but she got her anger got to the
surface you know there later on so
that's that's what this feels like
listening to you but I'm with John I
think you need to sit down a good pastor
a good marriage counselor somebody help
you unpack this I think it might be
easier than you think it is because you
were so able with your intellect to
verbalize where you are and so that you
you that's going to help is that you've
got a strong intellect to be able to
deal with this and that will help you
push the emotional process through